[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous merci
d'être avec nous sur TV 78 nous sommes
le jeudi 5 janvier voici le programme
c'est reparti pour le défi du mois de
janvier 31 jours sans boire une seule
goutte d'alcool il s'agit du dry Jenny
Mary initié par un collectif
d'associations les bienfaits sur la
santé seraient immense moins de
cholestérol meilleur qualité de sommeil
perte de poids mais surtout une
diminution des facteurs liés au cancer
dans le sang nous en parlerons avec Guy
Renou membres de la Ligue contre le
cancer des Yvelines et médecins après
les fêtes de fin d'année c'est déjà
l'épiphanie avec la fameuse galette des
rois dans cette émission un nouveau
emmènerons dans une boulangerie
yvelinoise pour vous faire découvrir les
secrets de fabrication et puis comme
d'habitude le jeudi à l'approche du
week-end nous vous donnerons nos idées
de sortie dans les Yvelines pièces de
théâtre exposition ce sera avec notre
journaliste Gabriel Gontier et après les
fêtes de fin d'année vous vous demandez
peut-être que faire de votre sapin de
Noël alors vous pouvez le jeter mais pas
n'importe comment pour en parler avec
nous Bruno Bruxelles bonsoir bonsoir
alors vous êtes mère adjoint délégué au
cadre de vie à Montigny-le-Bretonneux
alors première question que faire de son
sapin après les fêtes alors le sapin est
un élément important pour les fêtes de
fin d'année mais on essaye de lui donner
une seconde vie le recycler sous
différentes manières et donc il y aura
plusieurs points de collecte dans la
commune de Montigny il y a 21 points de
collecte donc on en parlera plus en
détail tout à l'heure dans cette
émission aussi vous vous demandez
peut-être après les fêtes comment faire
pour manger mieux plus sainement pour
nous conseiller Bérengère Philippon
bonsoir bonsoir alors vous êtes coach en
nutrition quelles sont les bonnes
habitudes à adopter après les fêtes de
fin d'année pour manger plus sainement
je pense que la première chose à faire
c'est d'éviter justement de faire un
régime hypocalorique de ce frustré au
maximum pour après recraquer très
rapidement derrière en tout cas c'est la
première chose à faire et donc on
parlera plus tard de plusieurs conseils
que vous allez nous donner avoir une
alimentation saine ça passe aussi par la
réduction de sa consommation d'alcool ça
tombe bien puisque tout au long du mois
de janvier il y a le drive genery on en
parlait c'est le défi du mois de janvier
pour boire pour ne pas boire d'alcool
durant tout le mois et justement avec
nous pour en parler Guy Renou bonsoir
vous êtes membre de la Ligue contre le
cancer des Yvelines et médecins alors
est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer
quels sont les bénéfices de ce mois sans
alcool si on tient tout le mois quels
seront les bénéfices sur notre santé
alors ils sont pas tous toujours
immédiats des fois il faut attendre un
petit peu mais alors au début il y a
quelques inconvénients il y a un peu
d'anxiété le fait de d'arrêter de boire
complètement il y a un peu d'anxiété
double du sommeil c'est un petit peu
difficile mais ça dure pas très
longtemps et en réalité et assez
rapidement les gens vous retrouvent
justement le sommeil on retrouve une
meilleure forme et comment au bout d'un
certain temps effectivement il y a des
pertes de poids et on voit une
amélioration de l'état général ce qui
est intéressant c'est que c'est les
Anglais ont montré qu'on commence en
2013 ont montré que cette amélioration
pouvait alors si on reprend pas
évidemment une consommation excessive
cette amélioration peut se poursuivre
pendant plusieurs mois ça permet c'est
le début pour commencer à bien réduire
ce qu'on appelle la détoxification tout
à fait on en parlera dans quelques
instants mais juste avant jetons un coup
d'oeil à la météo de demain
[Musique]
matin le sel devrait rester encore bien
couvert sur l'ensemble du département
attention aux averses du côté de
Mantes-la-Jolie et de Houdan au niveau
des températures il fera 11 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie et 10 degrés à
Versailles et Rambouillet dans
l'après-midi le sel devrait rester
couvert avec des averses sur l'ensemble
des Yvelines au niveau des températures
comptées 12 degrés en moyenne et demain
nous fêterons les saintes mélaines le
point maintenant sur l'actualité dans
les Yvelines
et c'est avec vous régime on commence
par le chiffre du jour 200 alors
pourquoi
200 c'est l'autonomie des véhicules
électriques que viennent d'acquérir les
pompiers des Yvelines c'est la première
fois en France que des pompiers passent
à l'électrique des panneaux solaires
seront également intégrés sur le toit
pour recharger la batterie des
différents équipements de la cabine la
livraison est prévue pour octobre 2023
au château de Grignon des meubles
d'époque ont été vendus à des prix
dérisoires lors d'une vente aux enchères
oui et cela s'est passé en juin dernier
l'école d'ingénieur agro ParisTech situé
au château Grignon
déménage à Paris Saclay l'État a donc
décidé de céder du mobilier via une
vente aux enchères en ligne les biens
mis en vente étaient qualifiés de style
et non d'époque c'est-à-dire peu anciens
et inspirer de l'histoire pourtant il
s'agissait bien de mobilier d'époque qui
allait de Louis XV à Napoléon III alors
à quel point les prix ont été bradés
régime alors je vais vous donner un
exemple à l'écran vous pouvez voir les
sièges Louis XVI ces derniers ont été
vendus à 6240 euros mais leur véritable
valeur serait estimée entre 300 000 et
500 000 euros d'après une récente
enquête du Canard Enchaîné pour le
moment des négociations sont en cours
pour récupérer les pièces mais comme les
meubles n'ont pas été inspectés avant
leur vente la justice pourra également
ordonner aux acheteurs de les restituer
une différence de prix quand même assez
énorme astronomique on continue avec le
colloque grand mât à
Saint-Lambert-des-Bois une trentaine de
physiciens et d'astronomes du monde
entier se réunissent jusqu'à demain à
Saint-Lambert-des-Bois leur point commun
ils font partie du projet grande main un
réseau de télé de télescope fondé en
2018 rassemblant 18 pays le cœur de leur
étude se base sur les ondes
gravitationnelles on écoute tout de
suite Sarah entier farfar
astrophysicienne et fondatrice du projet
grandement pour ne s'expliquer les
objectifs de ce colloque qu'est-ce que
c'est notre campagne d'observation en
fait c'est d'observer les phénomènes
extrêmement violents de notre univers et
en fait ces événements extrêmement
violents ils sont extrêmement rares
aussi et dès qu'on en a un il y a toute
une science qui est fait derrière ces
phénomène extrêmement violents ils nous
permettent de mieux comprendre par
exemple le taux d'expansion l'univers
comment se sont formés les premières
étoiles
aussi tester les lois de la physique
dans des conditions extrêmes et puis
aussi connaître comment se sont formés
nos éléments chimiques direction
Versailles une initiative est lancée
pour sauver les fonds qui meurent
pendant la période de fenaison oui
l'association patrimoniale de en pleine
de Versailles vient de lancer SOS fans
cette campagne de financement
participatif permettrait d'acheter un
drone thermique le but détecter la
présence des jeunes fins qui se taire
sous le foin pour se protéger des
prédateurs ces derniers sont décimés
chaque printemps par des faucheuses
pendant la période de fenaison qui ont
le rappelle consiste à couper et
récolter le foin à ce jour 545 euros ont
été récoltés sur la plateforme
hello-asso l'association espère
atteindre 9000 euros d'ici la fin de
l'année et on termine ces infos du jour
par une info sur le eSport régime vie et
l'équipe eSport athletex était donné
rendez-vous aujourd'hui au vélo de route
nationale de Saint-Quentin en Yvelines
l'occasion de renforcer la cohésion
d'équipe en ce début de saison ce club
professionnel fondé en 2020 a créé un
partenariat cet été avec la structure
olympique on écoute deux membres de
l'équipe pour nous parler de cette
journée
et sur un seul jeu c'est League of
Legend c'est notre jeu principal c'est
le jeu de réel numéro 1 on a
actuellement nous une division 2 donc
au départ on allait le sait qui est la
Ligue européenne la Ligue française et
on est juste en dessous on est convaincu
que le sport et l'esport ont des
connexions ont des choses mutuelles à
s'apporter et c'est vrai que
l'opportunité de pouvoir créer une
collaboration avec une complexe comme le
drone national c'est une opportunité
incroyable pourquoi pas accueillir aussi
des événements
compétitifs de créer des émissions
twitch il y a beaucoup de choses qu'on
peut créer dans ce complexe merci
beaucoup et si vous aussi comme
d'habitude vous voyez une information
qui vous a marqué près de chez vous
n'hésitez pas à nous le partager sur nos
réseaux sociaux en utilisant le hashtag
78 news
dans l'actualité également cette annonce
le parcours de parinise a été dévoilé
aujourd'hui il passera pour la 14e année
consécutive dans les Yvelines c'est la
verrière et la petite commune de
benzinville qui vont accueillir le
départ de l'épreuve pour la première
fois les détails avec Michael elmidoro
et Patrick Jacques de Dixmude c'est
officiel la ville de La Verrière 6000
habitants a été choisie pour lancer la
81e édition de la course cycliste
Paris-Nice le dimanche 5 mars prochain
les coureurs partiront de la
communivelinoise pour 169,4 km direction
la vallée de Chevreuse avant de revenir
vers le Mesnil-Saint-Denis en passant
par la côte des 17 tournants pour la
verrière ce sera une grande première cet
historique en un mot une vraie fierté
une vraie fierté pour la ville
d'accueillir un événement planétaire et
près de 8 millions de téléspectateurs
qui ont les yeux rivés sur la verrière
et puis sur le Mesnil-Saint-Denis
puisque l'étape part de la verrière et
arrive au Mesnil c'est un engouement
populaire c'est une étape sans précédent
dont on est vraiment très très fier
demain le lundi 6 mars et la petite
commune de Bazainville 1500 habitants
qui va accueillir l'épreuve le départ de
la deuxième étape sera donné place
Saint-Nicolas là aussi ce sera une
grande première pour la commune petite
commune très motivée par par l'enjeu et
bien situé aussi c'est dans la pleine
dedans donc encore une fois pas un arbre
pas de rien du tout donc une course qui
risque de partir vite c'est pas très
très connu vas-y mais chacun verra bien
que c'est un de ses charmants petits
villages tels que Nendaz dans les
Yvelines et c'est une façon pour nous
aussi de faire découvrir la richesse des
paysages des Yvelines les deux communes
vont accueillir de grands noms sur leur
terre le vainqueur du dernier Tour de
France yunas Wingard a déjà annoncé sa
présence du côté des Français en attend
David Gaudu romain Bardet ou encore
Arnaud démarre
le Parisis passera donc par la petite
commune de Bazainville avec ses 1500
habitants le maire Daniel Ferretti était
au micro de TV 78 il était évidemment
évidemment ravi écoutez
[Musique]
très grande fierté on remercie le
département d'avoir pensé à notre beau
village et on attend avec impatience ce
6 mars pour pouvoir accueillir cette
deuxième étape de Paris Nice
[Musique]
ça va se passer dans le centre village
donc on a déjà pensé à tout ce qui était
ramassage scolaire pour pouvoir mettre
en place des déviations mettre des
parkings pour que les gens du
centre-ville puissent le dimanche soir
mettre leur voiture à l'extérieur pour
pas qu'il soit gêné pour aller au
travail et on est en train de prévoir
des petites animations le dimanche avec
un petit parcours vélo et un petit
parcours VTT
[Musique]
on n'a pas du tout je suis rugbyman par
contre j'ai pierre Ferranti et
Jean-Louis bouissé qui sont des fervents
cyclistes qui sont tous les deux des
élus et qui sont très très contents de
pouvoir accueillir Paris-Nice moi je
suis très content mais eux en plus quand
ils sont comme des enfants avec
justement les les beaux vélos qu'on a vu
[Musique]
Brigitte Macron à Poisy championnat du
monde de cyclisme ou encore pénurie de
carburant dans les stations-service
voici les principaux événements qui ont
marqué les mois d'octobre à décembre
dans l'année 2022 le résumé de Gabriel
Gontier retour aux urnes après la
démission d'anne-grignon de son siège à
l'Assemblée nationale les électeurs de
la deuxième circonscription ont du voté
sans grande surprise Jean-Noël Barrault
l'emporte aux élections législatives
partielles devant Maïté qui arrive
bedouani de la nupes déjà membre du
gouvernement le ministre cette son siège
à sa suppléante Anne vergans en pleine
grève chez Total énergie et Esso exon
mobile près d'une station-service sur
trois connaît des difficultés
d'approvisionnement en France une
situation tendue également dans les
Yvelines situation compliquée aussi dans
tous les services pédiatriques en cause
une forte propagation de bronchiolite
chez les enfants le mois de
sensibilisation au cancer du sein et
lancé à l'occasion d'Octobre Rose la
première dame Brigitte Macron s'est
rendu aux trois arches à Poissy ce lieu
accompagne des personnes atteintes par
le cancer et l'émotion est encore vive
deux ans après l'assassinat de Samuel
Paty élu habitant professeur et élève se
sont réunis pour rendre hommage au
professeur assassiné par un terroriste à
Conflans-Sainte-Honorine durant les
championnats du monde de cyclisme sur
piste au vélo de Drôme de Saint-Quentin
en Yvelines la France terminale la
troisième place execo au tableau des
médailles avec trois titres remportés à
23 ans livelinoise Mathilde gros
remporte son premier titre mondial à
domicile l'occasion de se tester avant
Paris 2024 eux ont enfin pris la mer
après plusieurs jours d'attentes en
raison du mauvais temps les 128 skippers
de la Route du Rhum sont partis en début
d'après-midi de Saint-Malo direction la
Guadeloupe parmi aux deux yvelinesois
Laurent bolitain Louis Burton et le
versaillet Eric Bellion dans l'actualité
également décembre marqués par une
cyberattaque d'envergure visant
l'hôpital André Mignot au Chesnay
Rocancourt une cellule de crise a été
ouverte
alors on peut pas dire que le succès
phénoménal enfin il y a 10% des
personnes qui suivent effectivement ce
mois sans alcool et qui apparemment
respecte la procédure on en parle de
plus en plus
voyons on en parle de vous savez on a
tout à l'heure qui avait une application
drive trail que les gens peuvent
consulter apparemment le téléchargement
de cette application augmenter de 15%
c'est l'année dernière donc quel est
l'objectif de cette campagne est-ce que
penser c'est pour arrêter sa
consommation d'alcool ou en tout temps
tout du moins la réduire est-ce que
c'est aussi pour faire une introspection
sur soi-même pour se rendre compte à
quel point on peut consommer au nom de
l'alcool
la consommation d'alcool est quand même
extrêmement importante en France on
considère que 43 millions de personnes
qui boivent de l'alcool alors ça veut
pas dire que 43% d'alcoolique 43
millions d'alcooliques mais le problème
c'est que il y a 10% des alcooliques qui
consomment 58% de l'alcool consommé en
France donc cela sont vraiment dans très
très consommateurs alors c'est pas
forcément cela qui vont être le plus
concernés on parle bon pas s'intéresser
moi sans alcool par contre les gens qui
ont une consommation un petit peu au
dessus de ce qu'on conseille si vous
voulez vont probablement effectivement
bénéficier de cette procédure on
considère que au-delà de 3 verres alors
ce sont il s'agit de verres j'en vers
bistrot si vous voulez
au-delà de trois verres par jour on
considère que l'on dépasse on dépasse
déjà la dose conseiller ça c'est pour
les hommes pour les femmes c'est plutôt
deux on sait on conseille un petit peu
moins
pas cette différence entre homme et
femme
la réceptivité pas la même on parlera
peut-être des complications tout à
l'heure mais les complications chez les
femmes se mesurent directement
aux presque au vert près enfin l'idée on
arrive assez facilement
chiffré si vous voulez le risque
notamment pour les femmes dès
le premier pas dès le premier vers mais
dès qu'on dépasse la dose conseillée oui
un risque absolument oui alors quelles
sont les complications justement on peut
en parler maintenant ah bah les
complications de l'alcool elles sont
extrêmement nombreuses on considère que
le
ça remplit un peu les hôpitaux on
considère que le coûte de l'alcool de
l'alcool en France et d'environ 120
milliards d'apparence c'est-à-dire 6% du
PIB c'est considérable
l'alcool entraîne des complications en
dehors du cancer on les connaît c'est la
cirrhose du foie c'est
la pancréatite chronique c'est pas tout
un tas de complications et en plus il y
a le cancer alors le cancer par contre
au niveau de l'alcool c'est le cancer
des voies digestives supérieures la
langue la bouche
et là ce sont des cancers extrêmement
graves
sur
ces quelques
je crois que les gens qui sont soumis au
risque de plus importants sont très bien
informés quand vous avez des
gens qui consomment par exemple dans un
bistrot
il savent très bien que tel ou tel de
leur copains étaient atteint la cancer
qui démarre d'un cancer en fin les gens
les gens le savent
alors après il peut y a probablement ça
c'est les gros consommateurs par contre
les consommateurs moyens c'est pas sûr
c'est pas sûr on doit considérer que
quelques verres par jour c'est pas un
problème en fait si c'est un problème si
on dépasse trois verres par jour on
entre dans le problème à contrario
quelles sont les bénéfices sur sa santé
du coup si on arrête pendant un mois de
consommer de l'alcool ah bah les Anglais
vont bien démontré ils ont démontré
qu'il y a au début il y a quelques
inconvénients le fait d'arrêter de boire
de l'alcool ça vous rend un peu anxieux
ça vous ça trouve un peu votre sommeil
et puis un risque déshydratation parce
que l'alcool c'est quand même du liquide
et donc si on commence pas avec un autre
liquide il peut y avoir un risque
déshydratation alors les Anglais ont
montré que il y avait un bénéfice tout à
fait évident
une fois qu'on a passé ces inconvénients
là on retrouve un sommeil normal on
retrouve une meilleure forme
la perte de il y a une perte de poids on
récupère un poids normal alors qu'on
avait grossi avec l'alcool et ils ont
montré également que ces bénéfices là se
poursuivent pendant plusieurs semaines
voire plusieurs mois après après le mois
sans alcool donc ça a vraiment des
bénéfiques des effets bénéfiques c'est
ce qu'on appelle la détoxification en
particulier au niveau du foie est-ce que
vous allez tenter de relever le défi
autour du plateau est-ce que vous avez
vous êtes lancé dans vérifie là au mois
de janvier d'arrêter de consommer de
l'alcool Régine je bois déjà très très
peu d'alcool donc j'ai pas ce souci là
Bérengère Philippon moi j'ai de la
chance je n'aime pas ça
donc c'est très facile pour moi en tant
que coach on nutrition je suppose que
vraiment j'ai jamais aimé ça et j'ai
jamais essayé donc tant mieux comme
c'est moi qui conduit quand on rentre de
soirée et vous Bruno brussa du coup moi
je pense en écoutant les chiffres que
hormis les périodes de fêtes quelqu'un
boit ma part d'accord
et est-ce que du coup il vous avez déjà
des outils mis en place pour justement
motiver les personnes à continuer à
arrêter de consommer de l'alcool pendant
ce mois de janvier et les mois suivants
ce que vous mettez en place des
initiatives des au niveau de la Ligue
non puisque nous l'activité c'est
essentiellement ton aujourd'hui cancer
pas de pas de l'alcool mais je pense
qu'effectivement le seul rôle des
généralistes quand même de d'accompagner
leurs clients ils connaissent mieux que
n'importe qui et ils savent très bien
comment manager le ce retour si vous
voulez une à une hygiène normale
si on veut sortir de cette addiction il
faut plutôt se tourner vers son médecin
alors les généralistes au début si
l'addiction est trop importante il
faudra avoir à faire vraiment des
addictologues non c'est vraiment le
c'est difficile c'est très difficile et
bien merci beaucoup d'avoir accepté
notre invitation et si vous souhaitez
avoir plus de renseignements n'hésitez
pas à vous rendre sur le site internet
qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran après
les fêtes vous cherchez peut-être ou
jeter votre sapin alors sachez que votre
dans votre commune n'existe sûrement
quelques points de collecte Bruno
brusser vous êtes mère adjoint délégué
au cadre de vie de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux alors où est-ce
que se situe les points de collecte de
sapin dans la commune de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux alors sur
l'ensemble du territoire nous avons 21
sites il y en a devant la déchetterie
mais sinon on a en moyenne deux sites
par quartier une parcours nous avons 8
quartiers et ça fait 16 et certains
quartiers un peu plus grands
dispose de trois sites ça fait depuis
combien d'années en fait que vous avez
mis en place ce regroupage cette
collecte de sapins par quartier nous
avons souhaité la mettre
il faut se rappeler que qu'en 2014 nous
avions encore la compétence de gestion
des déchets et on avait souhaité
récupérer ces déchets pour les les
broyés et les abondés à monter les nos
espaces verts
et maintenant 50 ans en Yvelines
procède à une collecte mais une seule
fois dans le mois pour la ville de
Montigny ce sera le mardi 10 janvier
pour autant nous nous avons souhaité
continuer à offrir aux habitants la
possibilité de venir le déposer dans ces
espaces dédiés parce que on considère
qu'en une seule journée on récupère pas
tant de sa part que ça il y a des
personnes qui font le choix de l'enlever
très rapidement mais trois à quatre
semaines après on continue à avoir des
sapins des gens aiment bien avoir le
sapin chez eux et d'où notre collègue
dure jusqu'au 22 janvier et donc on peut
proposer son sapin n'importe comment où
il y a des règles à suivre quand même
non bien évidemment il faut que le sapin
se sont évidemment des sapins naturels
sans flocage donc que des sapins verts
neige blanche artificielle qui est
dessus
enlever toutes les décorations
si on dispose d'un sac à sapin
normalement il faut l'enlever bon les
agents des services techniques l'enlève
avant de le charger mais normalement on
le laisse nu et d'ailleurs Vous
sanctionnez où il y a des amendes pour
les dépôts de sapins sauvages
non ça serait difficile de retrouver le
propriétaire d'un sapin sur le domaine
public mais les gens jouent le jeu et
dès la première année on a eu un fort
engouement et on s'aperçoit aujourd'hui
que on récupère en moyenne 2500 ça a pas
par an avec des années meilleures que
d'autres ou moins bonne mais alors
juste pour finir c'est que la collecte
de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines on
s'aperçoit puisque ça fait deux ans
qu'il la font que après leur passage il
reste encore environ 50% des sapins donc
on en récupère encore beaucoup alors les
sapins nous on en garde une partie
qu'on boit et qu'on met sur nos espaces
notamment dans les jardins familiaux
dans les allées ou aussi sur les espaces
où il y a de la terre de bruyère pour
acidifier un peu le sol et le reste
après 50 le récupère pour l'envoyer à la
plateforme de compostage à
Plaisir-Grignon il y a du broyage de
sapin si on peut le dire comme ça qui
est redistribué aux habitants ou pas du
tout alors du broyage de sapin non pas
spécifiquement mais à la déchetterie de
Montigny
le prestataire mais à disposition du
compost
issu de la
plateforme de compostage de plaisir donc
nous on les habitants des pauses ont
récupéré on l'envoie là-bas et ils
peuvent venir après en déchetterie
récupérer le compost donc toute cette
mise en place c'est pour favoriser une
économie circulaire si on peut dire et
favoriser l'environnement
c'est dommage de brûler ça même si on
sait qu'aucidon
brûler c'est pas négatif puisque ça
fournit de l'électricité et du chauffage
à la commune de plaisir donc c'est
toujours intéressant mais c'est une
autre
c'est important pour maintenir la
fraîcheur sur les espaces verts et
éviter les mauvaises herbes
et bien merci Bruno brussart d'avoir à
mes questions est-ce que vous aimez la
galette des rois oui et bien j'ai une
bonne nouvelle pour vous ce matin
Ludivine non je n'ai pas fait de galette
pour l'instant mais Ludivine canard une
journaliste de la rédaction et Patrick
Jacques de Dixmude se sont levé très tôt
ce matin pour filmer une recette dans
une boulangerie yvelinoise il nous livre
les secrets de fabrication regardez
dans cette boulangerie Versailles la
préparation des galettes a commencé
depuis quelques jours pour réaliser une
bonne galette des rois tout commence par
la pâte feuilletée préparez tout ce
matin elle passe plusieurs fois sous le
laminoir
on aplatit la pâte et
jusqu'à avoir l'épaisseur voulue
[Musique]
c'est ensuite le moment du détailage
avec cette pâte Adrien peut découper
jusqu'à une trentaine de galettes après
un temps de repos au frais elle passe
sous les mains de Frédéric Rabin le
pâtissier
sur le côté ça aide que les deux restes
collées ensemble pour pas que la
garniture ne frangipane s'en
œil les galettes sont ensuite garnies de
la traditionnelle frangipane à ne pas
confondre avec une crème aux amandes la
frangipane elle est préparée avec de la
crème pâtissière
cette année les fèves sont en
partenariat avec le château de
Versailles mais malheureusement aucune
technique pour la trouver à coup sûr
donc après on prend les deux les deux
dessus
on essaye que ça soit
identique
après on ramène dessus et là on appuie
pour ramener les bords
c'est le moment déchiqueter la galette
un geste technique pour fermer la
galette et empêcher la frangipane de
sortir
après on donne à deuxième coup de dorure
et après on les raye et après on peut
après on peut les enfourner en fait les
galettes sont enfournées pendant 45
minutes en tout entre 5 et 7 heures sont
nécessaires pour réaliser une galette
compter près de 60 euros pour une
galette huit parts et 5 euros pour une
individuelle
et Ludivine canard et Gabriel Gontier
viennent de nous rejoindre dans le
plateau bonsoir bonsoir alors Ludivine
vous êtes levé très tôt ce matin pour
pouvoir filmer cette recette oui à 5h du
matin dans cette boulangerie la
préparation des galettes commencent à 1h
du matin et elle se termine en fin de
matinée il y a besoin de beaucoup de
temps de repos notamment dans les
chambres froides pour permettre à la
pâte de gonfler et puis comme vous
l'avez vu dans le reportage dans la
préparation de la galette il y a
beaucoup d'étapes et alors est-ce
qu'elle était bonne la galette alors
malheureusement je n'ai pas pu goûter
mais à l'odeur elle avait l'air très
bonne et du coup face à la crise
énergétique et à l'augmentation des prix
des matières premières est-ce que
comment est-ce que la gérante de cette
boulangerie s'organise comment elle s'en
sort alors
l'Épiphanie est une période importante
pour les boulangers elle représente 10 à
15% 10 chiffres annuels du chiffre
d'affaires annuel mais ce qui
préoccupait réellement cette Gironde
c'était la hausse du coup des
ingrédients notamment les œufs le beurre
et notamment
électricité je vous propose de l'écouter
ce qui est
favorisé plus le coût de l'énergie
quatre fours plus les chambres froides
ça a plus que doublé quoi mais ça a été
crescendo en fait on a commencé à voir
l'augmentation en septembre et là on
attend notre facture de janvier ou sert
les fesses du coup elle a augmenté son
prix de vente alors pour ne pas
répercuter ces hausses sur le prix de
ces galettes la gérante a décidé de
proposer des galettes au prix fixe donc
en fonction du poids de la galette pour
s'ajuster en fonction de ses coûts et
elle a également décidé de préparer ses
galettes à la demande pour limiter le
gaspillage et c'est cool merci beaucoup
Ludivine canard pour toutes ces
précisions on continue dans le domaine
de l'alimentation Bérengère Philippon
vous êtes coach en nutrition et vous
allez nous aider puisque après les repas
de fête bientôt l'épiphanie avec la
galette des rois et la Chandeleur qui
approche à grands comment est-ce qu'on
fait pour pour avoir pour adopter une
alimentation saine alors d'abord on
parlait tout à l'heure de l'alcool mais
il y a quelque chose qui est aussi très
important c'est tout ce qui est boissons
sucrées donc là aussi il faut vraiment
essayer de limiter parce que même un jus
de fruit va vous apporter 20 g de sucre
donc si on commence le matin par ça
c'est vraiment une bombe une bombe à
sucre et voilà si on veut déjà juste
essayer de faire un petit peu attention
de réduire ses boissons sucrées c'est
déjà une très très bonne idée après moi
ce que je conseille donc ce que je
disais tout à l'heure ne pas faire de
régime hypocalorique parce que ça c'est
la meilleure façon de craquer très
rapidement hypocalorique c'est vraiment
avec le régime très light 0 gras etc et
c'est vrai que en fait il faut vraiment
pas bannir le gras le gras ça va
apporter plein de bonnes choses
évidemment du gras qui est meilleur que
d'autres quel gras du coup voilà
effectivement dans mes recherches je
fais très attention je privilégie des
bonnes graisses après ça m'arrive aussi
de mettre du fromage je vous rassure
après je fais attention à la quantité au
cumul c'est ça qui est important mais
les bonnes graisses typiquement ça va
être cuisiner plus à l'huile d'OL veut
plutôt qu'auber ça va être tout ce qui
est oléagineux même dans les gâteaux à
la place du beurre on peut mettre des
purées d'oeilgineux ensuite il va avoir
tout ce qui est graines enfin et puis
les bonnes huiles qu'on utilise
qui vont pas automatiquement se cuire
mais par exemple quand on a une
poésie de légumes à la fin on peut
mettre un petit filet d'huile vous
pouvez mettre de l'huile de lin par
exemple qui est très bonne pour la santé
de l'huile de colza enfin il y a plein
d'huile qui sont très bonnes et ça on a
quand même davantage de goût quand on
rajoute du gras et on se fait plus
plaisir en mangeant donc ça va vraiment
permettre de de garder cette gourmandise
tout en ayant en fait des bonnes
graisses quoi alors on sait que le sucre
se cache dans les desserts dans le
chocolat mais est-ce qu'il peut se
cacher ailleurs
alors c'est vrai que c'est souvent le
problème les gens ne le savent pas mais
tout ce qui est un goût sucré
effectivement le repère très rapidement
par contre tout ce qui est féculent en
fait pas aussi enfin tout ce qui
contient de l'amidon va se transformer
en sucre dans le corps et c'est vrai que
les gens ça ne savent pas et donc c'est
pour ça que je la petite chose aussi à
faire c'est de réduire un petit peu sa
quantité de féculents pas ne plus en
prendre mais par exemple dans une
assiette ça va être à peu près un quart
de l'assiette et puis idéalement c'est
choisir des féculents qui vont avoir qui
vont être digérés un peu plus lentement
comme par exemple les légumineuses
légumineuses qui sont vraiment des
trésors nutritionnels ils sont très
riches en fibres en fait c'est ça qui
fait que derrière
on digère plus lentement et on est
rassasié plus longtemps ce qui fait que
deux trois ans après le repas on n'a pas
encore faim parce que ça reste bon en
général c'est vrai que quand on a un
plat de lentilles devant nous on en
mange moins qu'un gros plat de pâtes
donc voilà mais c'est vrai que ça
rassasie vraiment et il y a plein de
façons de les cuisiner moi je sais que
dans mes livres de cuisine j'essaie de
les mettre à l'honneur de montrer que
voilà ça peut être bon j'avais lumineuse
il y a plein de plats avec qui sont qui
permettent vraiment de faire plaisir et
c'est vraiment moi ce que je préconise
c'est de se faire plaisir en mangeant
mais voilà en choisissant des féculents
qui vont être plus rassasiants et plus
riche en fibres et qui vont vous éviter
d'avoir des pulsions sucrées après et de
craquer deux heures après le repas
en fait j'ai vu aussi dans un livre qui
s'appelle glucose révolution c'était
bien justement d'associer
des légumes avec des féculents pour
réduire justement ce sucre qui se trouve
dans les féculents c'est quelque chose
que vous conseillez aussi tout à fait
puisque en fait les féculents souvent
ils contiennent pas assez de fibres et
comme c'est les fibres qui permettent
d'avoir une digestion plus lente des
féculents pour éviter que ça se
transforme directement en sucre le fait
de rajouter des légumes en même temps ça
va apporter des fibres et moi je
considère enfin je conseille vraiment
d'avoir on va dire un quart de
l'assiette des féculents et la moitié de
l'assiette des légumes un légume
crudités
je vois qu'il y a pas mal de recettes
dans votre lit parce qu'il y en a qui
sont adaptés aussi pour les enfants on
sait que c'est des fois un peu plus
difficile de leur faire manger de tout
oui j'ai moi-même aussi deux enfants à
la maison donc oui oui après il y a des
il y a des recettes effectivement où
j'essaie de montrer qu'on peut faire
aimer les légumes aux enfants parce que
c'est souvent ça le problème par exemple
moi je cuisine beaucoup le légumes
évidemment dans les quiches parce que
c'est plus facile à faire passer dans
des gratins aussi des fois dans les
soupes etc ça se voit moins ça permet de
ça passe mieux mais enfin voilà moi je
sais que petit à petit ça commence à
venir et si on rajoute un petit peu de
fromage ou des petites sauces qui
peuvent être très saines on arrive à
faire plus facilement aimer les légumes
donc bref les enfants faut toujours y
aller plusieurs fois avant d'y arriver
mais
mais ça finit par marcher tout à l'heure
vous parliez de comment comment faire
enfin continuer à s'alimenter sans
craquer avec je sais pas une grosse
tablette de chocolat comment est-ce
qu'on fait justement pour éviter ces
craquages alors déjà moi le chocolat je
suis une très grande addicte et je
voulais quand même le dire que c'est
possible je parle à tous ceux qui
prennent du chocolat au lait qui adore
le chocolat au lait qui ont du mal avec
le chocolat noir c'est possible de
passer petit à petit au chocolat très
fort en cacao qui contient vraiment
moins de sucre et c'est vrai que pour ça
il faut y aller par étape moi je sais
que j'ai commencé par du chocolat blanc
c'est 30% de cacao donc j'ai augmenté il
existe du chocolat chocolat au lait il
existe du chocolat au lait qui est à 45%
55 65 même donc ça permet d'augmenter
petit à petit et après on passe au
chocolat noir à 70% 80 voilà moi je suis
arrivé à 4 entre 80 et 90 et c'est vrai
que on en prend moins en général ce que
c'est un peu plus fort et ça permet de
continuer à faire plaisir en fait avec
le chocolat et c'est vrai qu'en cas de
craquage de pulsion sucrée au moment du
goûter par exemple un petit carré de
chocolat noir comme ça avec une petite
poignée de la gineux ça peut vraiment
aider en fait à faire passer une pulsion
sucrée donc ça reste grave mais comme
c'est des graisses qui sont plutôt
saines on va vite calmer la pulsion
sucrée et en plus après ben on va voir
que c'est bon s'habitue et moi
maintenant m'écouter c'est plutôt ça
donc voilà
Gabriel vous aviez une autre question
particulièrement peut-être vous c'est un
livre du coup zéro sucre est-ce qu'il y
a des recettes sucrées aussi que vous
réinventez un peu alors moi je j'adore
créer les recettes donc effectivement
donc dans dans mon dernier ouvrage c'est
le troisième
j'ai beaucoup parlé en fait du fait de
de continuer à réussir sa détox sucre
puisque en fait mon premier ouvrage
s'appelle réussi ma détox sucre donc une
fois qu'on a failli on y est
l'intimité voilà parce que c'est sûr que
c'est pas évident de tenir sur la durée
et donc j'ai une partie un peu voilà
pour aider des astuces anti craquage etc
et effectivement après avec plus de 100
recettes c'est majoritairement des
recettes salées parce que en fait on se
rend compte que plus on va se faire
plaisir en salé en mangeant bien moi on
aura besoin de sucré et puis après ça
devient une habitude alors après j'ai
quand même mon deuxième livre était
consacré au dessert sucré justement moi
quand je dis que je mets enfin je dis
zéro sucre mais c'est plus on va dire
moins de sucre ça change j'utilise pas
du tout d'édulcorants parce que les
édulcorants sont pas très bons pour la
flore intestinale alors pas tous mais
voilà il y a quand même et puis ça
entretient l'addiction en fait au sucre
donc le but c'est pas de plus jamais
manger de sucre c'est d'en manger
nettement moins et on voit que au bout
de peu près vous comptez 3 semaines pour
que le corps en fait s'habitue et et
franchement c'est assez bluffant de voir
les pulsions sucrées qui disparaissent
de voir un bien-être derrière qui est
énorme ça reste une addiction aussi on
en parle peut-être pas assez mais c'est
une addiction et on peut s'en défaire
voilà tout à fait et bien merci beaucoup
Bérengère Philippon pour tous vos
conseils on va essayer de s'y tenir
après cette page nutrition on passe
maintenant à cette à la page loisirs
[Musique]
et c'est avec vous Gabriel Gonthier
comme chaque jeudi vous nous présentez
vos idées de sortie pour ce weekend oui
Mathilde et cette semaine on commence
avec du théâtre samedi soir l'Orchestre
National d'Île-de-France dirigé par le
chef d'orchestre espagnol Pablo Gonzalez
célèbre le redoutable Tsar Ivan le
Terrible qui a inspiré Sergueï Prokoviev
l'un des plus grands chefs
cinématographique du répertoire russe
alors l'orchestre se produira au Théâtre
de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines à 20h30 on
continue avec du théâtre et notamment la
résurrection d'un autre personnage dont
l'évocation d'un des frissons Gabriel
oui un personnage qui parle à tout le
monde Frankenstein un personnage
tellement célèbre qu'on en oublie
souvent le l'œuvre originale de Marie
Shelley à tout juste 19 ans au moment de
l'écriture alors cette fois c'est
Florian gouetts et Jérémy sontec qui
vont ressusciter l'oeuvre dans cette
pièce en voyage dans des atmosphères et
des époques différentes entre le 19e et
le 21e siècle notamment cette pièce elle
pose aussi la question de la à mesure de
l'être humain et de sa responsabilité
vis-à-vis de l'humanité et de son
environnement et c'est à découvrir cette
fois vendredi et samedi soir à 20h30 à
la ferme du Bel et bas à Guyancourt il
aura aussi un spectacle d'humour ce
week-end dans les Yvelines sans grande
surprise quand on parle d'humour ça se
passe au Théâtre de la Merise à Trappes
avec le compte de Bouderbala l'acteur et
humoriste Samy Ameziane se livre à un
stand-up mêlant sujet d'actualité sujet
intemporel et anecdote personnelle alors
c'est la troisième édition du spectacle
les deux précédentes avaient rassemblé 2
millions de spectateurs et je crois
qu'un autre humoriste est de passage
dans les Yvelines cette fois dans la
ville de Buc qui accueille l'humoriste
Michael Hirsch qui revient avec un
nouveau spectacle sur le sommeil et le
rêve dans jeu pionce donc je suis
l'humoriste et interprète l'humoriste
interprète par nantour à tour une
vingtaine de personnages drôles absurde
et poétique il invite son public arrivé
les yeux grands ouverts et on termine
par une exposition
de hauts Gabriel une exposition qui
s'appelle résonance intime c'est une
exposition qui invite vous l'avez dit
Mathilde au questionnements sur son
rapport à soi à son corps à son image ce
qui est intéressant ici c'est qu'il
s'agit d'un travail collaboratif en
partenariat avec le Théâtre Eurydice
sauvegarde de plaisir et le pôle art et
handicap des Yvelines et des Hauts de
Seine au travers des photographies
exposées le la meta en scène interroge
les participants sur leur rapport à leur
corps alors l'exposition elle est à
découvrir au donjon de Houdan jusqu'au
11 janvier merci beaucoup Gabriel
Gontier alors comme d'habitude est-ce
que vous avez des préférences autour du
plateau une idée de sortie qui vous
tente plus qu'une autre
c'est bientôt la fin de cette émission
mais juste avant jetons un coup d'oeil à
la météo de demain
[Musique]
matin le ciel devrait être encore bien
couvert sur l'ensemble du département
attention aux averses du côté de
Mantes-la-Jolie et de Houdan au niveau
des températures il fera 11 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie et 10 degrés à Houdan
Versailles et Rambouillet dans
l'après-midi le ciel devrait rester
couvert avec des averses sur l'ensemble
des Yvelines au niveau des températures
comptées 12 degrés en moyenne et pour ce
week-end Gabriel quel est le temps
douce et pluvieuse pour ce week-end
samedi dans la matinée les températures
seront comprises entre et 7 degrés sur
l'ensemble du département avec un ciel
voilé mais ensoleillé l'après-midi la
plus fait son apparition comptait 8
degrés à Rambouillet et 10 degrés à
Houdan et Mantes-la-Jolie dimanche la
tendance reste la même malgré la pluie
et les nuages la matinée sera
partiellement ensoleillée comptait des
températures entre 8 et 9 degrés
l'après-midi peu de changement il fera 8
à Rambouillet 9 à Versailles ou dans et
Mantes-la-Jolie merci beaucoup Gabriel
c'est la fin de cette émission merci
pour votre fidélité je vous souhaite une
belle soirée sur TV 78 prenez soin de
vous
[Musique]